Albert was a shining god
of comedy.
He was speaking directly to me.
(LAUGHS)
Always something just different.
He was like a comedic tornado.
Just fearless and funny.
He's so fuckin' hot.
It took this
to finally hear a compliment.
-(LAUGHS)
-Can't wait till I'm dead.
ROB REINER:
So, here's the thing.
We've been friends for, like,
almost 60 years.
I've always looked up to you
and what you could do
with comedy.
I did 100 variety shows.
Albert Brooks!
-Albert Brooks.
Albert Brooks.
This... This isn't me.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
You're the only guy I know
who would go
on national television
with a routine
that you had never tried out.
ALBERT BROOKS:
I went in the bathroom,
I would come up with something,
and I would go do it.
Not only don't you have
any money,
but your sister is dead!
That was funny.
♪ (UPLIFTING MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
He was the first
alternative comic.
I think of him
as the caviar of comedy.
This guy's really special.
CHRIS ROCK: He's so good,
you can't steal it.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
If you stole it,
you wouldn't know
what to do with it.
I mean, he's a beautiful actor.
He has all that technique.
He can do anything.
And I'm in love with you.
How do you like that?
I buried the lede.
ALBERT:
Stanley Kubrick called me
and said,
"This is the jealousy movie
I've always wanted to make."
You've heard of
a no-win situation, haven't you?
-Vietnam, this.
-No.
I'm telling you, they're around.
I think we're in one of them.
Everything he was talking about
is what television turned into.
Film the gynecologist?
What you didn't want to happen
watching
an Albert Brook's movie,
you never wanted the scenes
to ever end.
Defending Your Life was one
of the most insightful films
I had ever seen.
-Hi. How'd you die?
-On stage, like you.
(LAUGHTER)
To me,
genius is you have the idea
and then the courage
to execute it.
(LAUGHTER)
I would rather have
Albert's career than my career.
ROB: I mean,
I'm listening to all this,
and I'm getting a person
who's been defending his life.
Every goddamn minute.
ROB: Yeah.
ALBERT: My agent said,
"I don't know why
you always take the hard road."
-(SCREAMS)
-You think I see two roads.
-Yeah.
-I see one road!
Because this... (SCOFFS)
this isn't me.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
It's not the real me.
♪ (PIANO MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
This...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...is the real me.
He's the funniest man
in the world.
(APPLAUSE)
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪